because just as i unearthed there was a
memo the d.a in manhattan cybants
handed out right after one of the huge
protests which involved looting and
burning and anarchists and
and and all kinds of uh uh a theft
the d.a comes out in this internal memo
to his staff and he says we're going to
give the protesters their protesters
mind you they're protesters yeah i'm
approaching cds
or dismissals but if any of those
protesters have
any information about police mis
behaving in their arrest or mishandling
them
we will take those cases and prosecute
them
so let the protesters go and turn turn
it the tables
on the cops really two cops in compton
you know i mean i'm sick i'm sick
people laughing people laughing a woman
shot through the jaw trying to say what
her number
is this is not america
people always say this is the most
important election in your lifetime
i really mean it this time i mean i
would take an oath
on this you know i would go to church on
this um
because there's so much at stake and
we're right at the precipice where
it'll all fall i spent
32 years in law enforcement in the
courts in the criminal justice system
uh i know that that that is my
wheelhouse
and what is happening now with the
defunding of police
with the stand down police orders with
the no bail
with prosecutors who are refusing to
prosecute
what we've got now is total anarchy
and when the left talks about open
borders
locking you down defunding the police
and when kamala harris says the
constitution doesn't stop her
from taking away our guns we got real
problems
we've got real problems and you know
what i think
i think not just the people who live in
the cities that have been destroyed
milwaukee
kenosha which is small town america
milwaukee and chicago and
and and seattle and portland and detroit
and
uh not detroit so much they're in good
shape but washington and so many cities
new york city
i mean the democrats know what they need
and they need law enforcement they need
a criminal justice people in the inner
city
know that the vast majority of victims
of of of a crime
are a black on black crime okay
they know they need protection and so
the black reverends the hispanic pastors
and all that other sub priests
they want law enforcement in the
community but the criminals are now
emboldened i'm not telling you anything
you don't already know and that you talk
about dave
but this is the last chance people are
walking around with guns in their in
their
in their waistbands they're not worried
about anything because
just as i unearthed there was a memo the
d.a in manhattan cybans
handed out right after one of the huge
protests which involved looting and
burning and anarchists and
and all kinds of uh uh a theft
the d.a comes out in this internal memo
to his staff and he says we're gonna
give the protesters their protesters
mind you they're protesters yeah
approaching cds
or dismissals but if any of those
protesters have
any information about police misbehaving
in their arrest or mishandling them we
will take those
cases and prosecute them so let the
protesters go
and turn turn it the tables on the cops
really two cops in compton
you know i mean i'm sick i'm sick
people laughing people laughing a woman
shot through the jaw
trying to say what her number is this is
not america
how worried are you that the state of
the state of the system because of
everything that you just described there
that in a certain way it almost has to
get worse before it can get better that
you can't get a reset
when you have so many sort of cowardly
da's
now cowardly it's i don't blame the a
lot of the police chiefs or the average
policeman
who's retiring early i don't blame him
it's like if you're not going to be
backed up by your politicians i don't
blame them
but do you think it has to get worse
because enough of them will have to
disappear
and maybe you have to then vote in
completely new
politicians most likely republicans
without
complete chaos happening that it can't
reset otherwise
well i think two things i think number
one
it has to get worse and it will get
worse
okay there's no question the president
is not going to use insurrection
unless it does get worse he said the
time is is not now
um and i also think that these
i'm so sorry
you got your own insurrection over there
yeah i'm so sorry
um but i also think that um
these these politicians these
prosecutors are
in i mean they're not going to be voted
out for a few years
but the money that's coming in to
support antifa
outside money and the money that's
coming in to fund these people flying
from one city to another city where
they're bailed out in one city to then
go to another city
i mean there's big money behind the
destruction of this country
all right so let's let's just hit a
couple other things that you go into in
the book so since we've talked about
new york and so much of your your
history is in new york uh you're not a
fan
of bill de blasio the uh the mayor of
new york city
i believe you call him bozo de blasio
um are you shocked how quickly the city
has devolved
under him even even though i know you
don't agree with any of his policies but
like
just the rapid rate that so much of the
city has just turned into chaos
look the man is either stupid
incompetent
or both all right that's what i think of
bozo
the guy is a bozo i mean first of all
the fact that he would move to defund
the police
the fact that he started half of this
police uh
hatred in new york he's been very very
much
pushing that agenda he doesn't support
the police and i talked to a lot of the
upper echelon in the police department
the top ranks there
i mean they he they cannot deal with him
and he can't deal with them he's never
been a fan of law enforcement
but by not deploying police
when there was looting going on on fifth
avenue in manhattan now i'm not saying
because that you know they're wealthier
there they deserve protection i'm not
saying that at all
because if you got a bodega and that's
all you got then that's your castle and
you deserve protection
because you're paying taxes too but
things that are so obvious
so apparent all you have to do is deploy
the the
the police he didn't do it i mean i was
told
he told them you're going to stand down
or we're not deploying them the same
with macy's in harold square
they're trying to start a fire in macy's
why is he so happy with that
and the dumbest thing the man ever said
when he said
oh no these are peaceful protesters
you're blind too
um where he says we're going to allow
them to protest
because this is a historic moment in
history
are you kidding it's a historic moment
in history
but don't you dare go to church don't
don't you jews dare have a funeral
don't you dare do any go back to work
don't you dare
and then then cuomo wants to deploy what
was a 4
000 please to monitor the uh
restaurants to make sure people are
wearing masks when they go in the
restaurants
when you don't have police a woman was
raped on a platform
you know in the middle of the day there
are people walking around in manhattan
men without their pants on
and they're drinking alcohol from a
paper bag in a pla a flask in a paper
bag
i mean he the man doesn't have a clue if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell